this is only going to be about a
30-minute talk so we should have plenty
of time at the end for any kind of
question discussion or
whatever we want everybody else wants to
talk to after all this
um
and this is a project that i've worked
on over the years and it keeps coming
back so that's one of the reasons why i
decided to bring this up with a
marketing group i've been in and out of
marketing groups
for the past few years and also worked
in marketing research
and
so a little bit about me um
i am a head of manager of analytics data
science at a small bank in boston
um i started out in chemistry and then
got an mba
did a lot of work in the insurance
industry doing some pretty exotic stuff
um
got heavily involved in monte carlo and
pricing
um
and then got involved in quant banking
consulting so i i think as you can see
like every other data scientist i just
want the exact straight route out of
college into data science
so what we're going to talk about here
is what this project is all about uh and
i'm going to try to give it to you in a
way so that you can take this to your to
your next pr
marketing project
um talk a little bit about what good
survey design is or what i think it is
um there's an interesting uh bit of
intellectual property that the
ability to work on called customer
quotient uh similar in a way to nps but
also very different
look at some parameters to constraints
then getting involved in the machine
learning part of how do you actually do
machine learning with survey data
so
the role of this was how do you how do
you take a survey because that's what a
lot of people in marketing research do
and develop a segmentation engine out of
it so that as people
complete your survey
you can put them in the right segment
for whatever and you can segments can be
based on whatever um in this case this
was a
sort of a behavioral psychographic
segmentation which means it wasn't so
much
you bought product a b or you live in
this part of the world or
wherever this is more about how you feel
and how you behave
um and so it gives you a little
different um approach to sort of the
different dimensions of marketing
um
it was
looking to
reveal this is again this is part of a
much larger project
how people
view
companies you know and the other way to
think about it is
it at the end of the day it rates how
customer
um centric a company is
and that's how that's how the questions
were sort of phrased
so these are some of the things that
i've learned about what makes a good
survey and
these are just my these are my takeaways
from from being involved in surveys and
trying to apply machine learning and
um
you know how do you get it how do you
ensure you get a lot of respondents etc
so
the first thing is i want a goal of like
what is the survey to decide to answer
um
and then
you're going to want to have some
supporting questions so let's think of
it structurally that's when that's how
we want to start it
in the goal you shouldn't have more than
three things you're trying to answer i
usually say one to two is good
um just in case you know you get you
pick up some other ancillary information
um and these goal statements are
binaries yes knows
my first experience was um
dealing with the survey and people were
like well how likely are you to
um purchase from us again and so you end
up with these neutral you know
everybody's in the neutral range and it
doesn't really help you out or what do
you do when you get
a handful at the positive hand and
handle the negligent handful of neutrals
you drop them do you include them with
something else so this sort of resolves
that issue it's a simple yes no
um with that the supporting questions
you want
as few as you can get away with
um but still get the information that
you want so you know i like to think
maybe between five and ten questions
um
if you start getting over 10 questions
you're just getting too much you're
asking for too much information
and you'll find that people will drop
out
over time
um the flip side around it is in the
marketing research world you do have the
ability to pay people with
uh pick your incentive amazon gift card
paypal whatever else they will stay in
for a longer
knowing that if they finish it they'll
get some money at the end
and
i've done a couple of the i've done many
of both
uh and there doesn't seem to be a
difference in engagement as far as like
you get different answers if you pay
people um
and then
here's a key thing
i like my supporting questions so we got
our we got our one binary like now
instead of what how likely are you to
buy from me again is
i i have bought from you again or i will
buy from you again yes or no
um
and then we're to ask a bunch of
questions that support it
um and i think everybody's seen these
strongly agree gray neutral
etc i do not like that scale
um
one you don't get as much variability in
the modeling phase
whereas 1 to 10 gives you plenty of
variability and i think if you go over
more than 10 people don't know what the
numbers mean
and just as a little aside i worked in
the wine industry for a while and
you know they have their 100 point wine
scale but the funny thing is 99 point
whatever percentage of the wines are
ranked between
80 and 100 so what they really have is a
20 point scale
um and so i don't know they disguise it
as a nine as a hundred point scale
versus twenty point scale same thing
here
um
ten points will give you enough
variability
um
and then the other thing is you know
people always say oh we can ask a
question a different way to make sure
that we don't have people gaming the
system
um
maybe if you get this giant survey that
or like a personality test or something
like that but that's a whole different
animal here
um
if you're surveying your customers
they're not going to they're not going
to do the duplicates and if they start
seeing the bible it's going to be like
this is a waste of time and it's also a
waste of
your time too like every question
matters
um
and i've seen some other indices out
there
where they have like
uh they try to decompose like a net
promoter score
which into three indices and it's kind
of like
they're the three indices are so
incredibly correlated that you just
wasted two questions
every asking about the other two indices
when
they're they're like ninety percent
correlated so it's kind of like you
really have one index
um
in the marketing world i know anybody's
worked in barcelona he's heard a net
from motorsport it's kind of a hybrid
because it because it does ask on a
scale of one to ten but you can also but
at the end of the day you can make
people binaries out of it in fact there
is a um you know people that score you
um
nine and ten are your promoters uh six
to eight to your neutrals and
five and below are your
detractors and in the score only works
with uh promoters and detractors so it's
a very unique um scale but when you do
nps you should really ask you know get
into the whys
um
and then a good rule of thumb is to try
to get about a thousand responses um
because you can do some really good
modeling i know everybody thinks oh this
is the world of big data i need ten
thousand a hundred thousand eight a
million no you don't
um you need a well-designed survey
and if you get close to a thousand
responses you will get a reasonable
amount of information
um
what's interesting
about surveys
is that if your questions are
distinctive enough
then even if you get smaller segments
you will be able to predict them so for
instance
you know
segment one is questions one two three
and then
you know segment two is
maybe a question three and question four
but then segment three is oddball
question question five
even if it comes out small and you get
into this highly imbalanced um
data scenario the fact that question 5
is so unique it will help
even with the prediction in an
imbalanced situation because
it's not random
so a little bit about customer quotient
this was developed by
a colleague of mine at sea space in
boston dr manila austin
and it talks and it builds on this
custom this sort of
how
customer centered is your company
and they ask questions from from the
customer's perspective and you build up
the pyramid from you know relevance
you're just in the game at that point
um then we have a customer series
questions around customer experience how
well you do
then the better you are you get into
openness
and that begins to really unlock the
doors
um
are you willing to have an honest and
open two-way dialogue with your
customers
um
empathy is really the
what
changes the game so when when i've seen
companies in the segments
um it's not until you do reasonably well
at the openness and get into empathy
that you begin to really like we've
grouped different
um companies and segments and everything
else and you see when you start rating
up on the empathy scores you begin to
run away um and become extremely well
and the last one is what we call
emotional validation those are the
people out there that are selling your
product
on their recommendations
um
we used to talk about is you have two
people you have three people having a
conversation someone says i need to get
a new um smartphone and the first person
says get an iphone phone and the other
person really doesn't say anything so
your iphone is your sort of emotional
validation person and they'll give you
five reasons why you should get an
iphone or on the flip side they'll give
you five reasons
why you should get an android or
whatever it is but they are selling your
product it's called emotional validation
those are your
ultimate customers because they are
doing your marketing
when we find that people that score
higher up there actually have to spend
less in marketing and advertisement over
the long term and they give some better
scores that's just a little bit of this
intellectual property area in the space
that i worked on here
um for those with traditional marketing
backgrounds where you talk about the
four ps and the three c's and all those
so the four fees product price place and
promotion
um
the three c's are customer company and
um competition and what these do is sort
of map
various questions that help with the um
cq scoring
you know into these different um
traditional marketing buckets so that
like when we when we talked about
pitching this to different companies
if i had a traditional marketer i could
say yeah this is your product piece this
is your price piece and you can see
um like price
um
it's all from that customer point of
view
the company appreciates my loyalty and
that's literally how the question worked
it's an action word or i don't feel
ripped off
um
and
you can see in most of these questions
and these are sort of um
paraphrases of it but we've
we've made it action oriented and it's
from the customer standpoint not i
versus if you see think about a lot of
quick surveys is the company is asking
do you like us
you know
do we do a good job at this and things
like that whereas
this whole framework really reverses it
around
so let's talk about this this project
that we had
client specification number one had to
be built in excel
and
that happens you know i wish i could
just do it in markdown or something easy
like that or a web app but
um
at the same time as it's workable
what it does do is it changes the model
processing a little bit you know i'm not
gonna be able to run xg boost or any of
that
but at the same time i may not need to
and and there's a good way that i get
around this down the road
um our sample size was 900 not a
thousand
but that's fine
um
and it's like okay
probably only gonna get about three or
four segments out of this
and part of this came out of is that a
major
company was
um
had a project with a major consulting
company and they said well you have
eight eight distinctive segments
and it was like okay really
um so we're going to test out whether we
really have eight distinctive behaviors
um by using this this survey
um
in the initial step and this is one of
the things that he said um
this one did not have the dependent
variable um and that's that's why i want
that's why i added it in early on as a
good survey has a
binary outcome so we had to create one
or create some sort of segmentation
outcome
the nice thing is survey questions on a
110 scale easy to work with
and if you think about it
from the machine learning world as we go
down the road
um
we're not going to have to center scale
or do any of that with the data it's
already pre-packaged on a one-to-ten
scale um
and
you know we're good whether we do
any kind of and we're going to do
unsupervised learning or supervised
you're not going to have to
rescale all the data which makes it
which makes it nice
um
and when you do some of these things and
and these n ones are
you know my discussion with them
um
you know what's good enough accuracy
um
are there penalties for you know false
positives or false negatives like if we
put the person in the wrong segment
you know how costly is it to your
business
um
and
um should we
add penalties if they are costly in one
way or another
um
and that would change a little bit of
the modeling too um we would add we
would actually add a cost
matrix into it down the road if we had
to
but in this case
there weren't too many big deals and
they said you know what
you gave me 80 of the way you gave me 80
of the right answers
i'll be happy
i was like okay 80 85 that's worth shoot
for
hopefully we can do better that's one of
the things for me is
i always like to be in the 90s um
but
sometimes it doesn't always work out
that way
so here's a little road map here and you
can use this
over and over like anytime any kind of
survey work you do
i've used this
format
for
a lot of nps modeling that i've done for
various companies over time
design a nice survey so we asked for for
nps people we asked that question but
then we asked them questions about
customer service we asked them questions
about pricing
other aspects of the business
to see what what you're trying to do is
figure out what drives that answer what
drives that yes no
um
so then we're going to do some
clustering i like hierarchical
clustering it's easy visualization the
scale is easy so we're gonna um
separate our
respondents into some
different segments and clusters
uh then we're gonna create a dummy
variable for each one so you so right
you know
you're in segment one or you're not
you're in segment two you're not you're
in segment three or you're not
um
i think a lot of people try to go
straight to sort of a multinomial model
hey we're just gonna predict what
segment you're in right out of with one
equation
those require a lot of data so yeah if
you're in one of these big data worlds
and you've got ten thousands or fifty
thousand
um
you could probably pull it off with a
thousand
simple binaries are gonna be the way to
go
so here's my little my little magic here
what what i first do is use the elastic
net regression
um the glen net model the glen net
package by um trevor hassan rob
subterranean
it was designed for genomics
it really will help you reduce
dimensionality
um and it's extremely fast
and uh to give you a little bit more
information on this um
those people that are familiar with
ridge
or lasso regression
this is the hybrid so a
ridge will attempt to
squeeze down all your coefficients to
make them very small
and the lasso will do is if there are
multiple variables that are correlated
the lasso will pick one and leave the
other ones out now the problem with
lasso regression
is you don't know why it made the
decision
um
is it
you know a function of the gradient
descent or function of the order of the
data you just don't know
and they talk about it in their paper
about that whereas what the elastic net
does is i have three variables that are
correlated
if they're statistically valid we leave
them all we leave all three in if
they're just not statistically valid we
pull them all out
um
and so that's why it how it gets to your
dimensionality reduction
so then this last step is all right we
got to go into excel now you probably
could do an elastic net maybe not
in excel but you can easily do a
logistic regression and so what we're
going to do is
build out our template so when we get
batches of scores
we just run them through our
work worksheet with logistic regression
in there
and then it's gonna
use a voting method
and it'll choose which segment you're in
so the first thing did is we run this um
the elbow famous elbow plot used for
clustering and it's called within this
sum of the squares residuals um and so
what we got is number of clusters they
told me they had eight segments so i
went for up to eight clusters at least
their consulting company did
and what we're looking for is the bend
in the plot and you can see
you get the elbow at about three or four
at which point then it all sort of
flattens out so
if i had a lot more data i probably
would shoot for four clusters
given that it was only 900 respondents
three would probably do the job um you
can see that
the uh sum of the squares
uh
goes down obviously the most between one
two and three between three and four
it's very little and after that tails
off so that's why we're looking at that
um inflection point
um so we plot them all out visually
we get three groups
um
and this is a you know you can see in
the hierarchical clustering
um
that you get the divisions
almost fairly cleanly between the blue
block and the green block
um
and then the green block and the red
block and the other way to interpret
this is
the people in the blue block
are very different from the people in
the
red red segment
and there's some gradations across the
middle
i use this plot a lot when i do
text analytics because it's really fun
then
um because what you're seeing is when
you do this with text as these people
are saying one thing
they're saying something similar to
these guys
but now it's getting different and then
you get something really weird at the
other end um
so i i like this
plot from a visual standpoint
and the access the other axis is so is
just the distance distance metric
and as i as i mentioned because all of
our questions were one to ten scale
um i didn't have to rescale anything um
to make to be able to do this clustering
and yep this is small
and it may be difficult to predict but
it doesn't automatically mean that
because as i said if there are certain
questions
that are answered by a handful of people
in the group that makes them marketably
different
then you'll still be pretty good at
predicting whether or not people are in
there
so this is when i overlay my cluster
analysis across their eight segments it
was kind of interesting i was like
well
you may have eight segments but you have
three distinct behaviors within each
segment
and what i mean is that you know there
is this grouping here
we'll call number one for now behavior
one
that seems to cut across all of them
with an exception of these of this
segment
and we also have behavior two
there's people in the in betweens but
then this behavior number five stands
out
um
and it appears that this convenience
store resellers segment is actually kind
of small in general
um
[Music]
but looking at those numbers
it's pretty clear that we have
you know you could describe it two
different ways you can say
we have eight segments with three
behaviors
or you could say
i actually have 24 segments
so
granted that i have this social couple
there are actually three forms of social
couples
now one one of the
interesting things about
looking at some of these segments is
um
what about people that would be crossing
over some of them like how do they
specif how did the company specifically
put them in each segment
and can you move or will you move over
time like how long do you stay a new mom
um
and
you know
how long you stay a social company
some of these others are a little bit
more static but
um
we got a nice clean picture here so it's
good we
our elbow plot told us we had three or
four segments
and most likely three our hierarchical
clustering came up with about three
segments and we can see it here
so the size thing is so we have three
segments three equations
so here's here's a little bit more on
the elastic net
um
the reason why i use it is it it's going
to give me
my upper bound of performance or
accuracy in this case
um
we because my goal is to get it down to
a logistic regression with a couple of
questions
um
but if if
if my last net commit comes in only at
80 percent accurate on the rough before
we even do any kind of dimensionality
reduction
then my logistic regression isn't going
to cross my 80 threshold
so that's going to be problematic down
down the road
um and the way it works is you know you
think about your logistic regression
it's you're in segment one or not you're
in segment two or not and the
probability you're in segment three or
not
and
for each person you get three scores and
the highest score wins so in this case
the person this the data point came back
the probability in segment three was 90
percent it beats 55 it beats 21
therefore they get assigned to segment
three
um
versus i think when you think about your
traditional way of just using a single
um logistic regression you generally
assign your probability at fifty percent
and if it's greater than fifty it's in
that segment
um here we're using a little uh
uh an ensembling type approach and we're
gonna we're gonna vote basically
um
standard
split training testing so
you know 900 data points
gets me 250
testing and
you know 650 training it's not great
it's not bad
um
how do we do
so here's the first segment segment
number one
um the lasting net regression
near perfect
very little
um
false positives false negatives
good split here so it's not so
unbalanced that basically it's an easy
guess um so this is nice 99.26 really
good
um
and what so you see down here when we
did these to see i'm not going to sort
of show you the same plot three
different times um
and um another key piece to look at is
this this no information rate 0.61 that
is essentially your data split
if the no information rate in this was
90
or 0.90 or something or higher than that
which when you get in imbalanced data
sets
then that
you know that 95 99 well it's a good
lift but it's not as impressive versus
we're at 60
on a random guess
and
you know we're near 100 accurate
and you can see we got 94 on this
segment 2 and 80 in this small segment
that's
that's not surprising we knew it was
going to be a small segment we knew it
was going to be a little more
challenging
but it's still
for the client standpoint they're quite
happy with what they were seeing
initially
this is a nice little variable
importance plot with the
elastic model and you've got your
questions
ranked order of importance
and when the when the
plots out this way that means they put
you in the segment
um and you'll see in another plot they
go the other way they say and when you
answer this question it gets you out of
the segment
and now there's others more
sophisticated approaches out there
there's lime
that's probably the most common now that
people are using
locally interpretable modeling
but this
one of the things that tells me now is i
can begin to remove some of the
questions from this equation right
what i'm trying to do is make it
simplify this as much as possible so i'm
going to say for segment one
we're just going to use a couple of
questions so that now i only have three
variables for this equation
make perfectly easy simple for it
especially since we don't have a lot of
data
and so what did model ones what question
one segment one say well they appreciate
my loyalty
i feel proud
sense of belonging
and they believe the company
employees use their own products and
service
so
this is
we think the um the highly correlated to
an emotional validation segment
um
and so
these are your these are your really
good customers you want to take care of
them you want to know who these people
are
in the world of uh computer vision i was
at a conference
back when we used to go to those things
and live person and someone said
they should you should run your image
recognition about at your customers when
they come in your bank because
you know
they match the face and the balance or
something like that and come up and say
wow this person's like a really big
customer you should do something to take
care of them um
interesting portrayal but you know
someone would say yeah but everybody's a
important customer they're just
just another way to think about
how do you take care of
your loyal customers and how do you show
them their loyalty and that's a
question 16 is an important one
um
and uh i know
when we were doing this we're presenting
something like this
uh to some internal people um
my marketing research person used the
concept of amazon pantry she's like
so they get it wrong all the time
but they make it right all the time so
yeah maybe
i order six things and five out of the
six are right and one of them's wrong
but so they always make it right and i
think that's that part of that
how do you get you know even if you
mistake make a mistake how do you get
people coming back to you and it's all
about you know fixing your errors
as a marketer and as a company
so now so when i reduce it down
this is that what i said is we're going
to go to a simple logistic progression
with just a couple questions
i lose a little bit accuracy so
um
so rather than almost a perfect
with only one offender we've actually
begun to make a little bit more
um
false negatives or false positives here
as we think they're in
segment one but they're really not
but we're still at 94 so we're good
um
and we're not again we got our no
information rate so it's we've got good
lift
uh we now have a happy uh logistic
regression model for segment one
so segment two as i said looking at the
variable importance
these when you answer these questions a
certain way they actually pull you out
of the segment so you need them as a way
to
separate out segment one from segment
two
um
and if we ran this through lime you
would actually see
a red and green well if you use the
traditional colors you'll see red and
green scoring for these questions that
um they're important because they will
either put you in or put push you out of
the segment
and these are a different set of
questions we see so
our 16s and 21s as you can see
are up here
not as important
and
here we're imbalanced
and it's a mixed accuracy
right so yeah we think we're really good
but most of these people are getting
pushed out in the other segment
um
and this is the this is the logistic
regression model we're making
and that's where i said that no
information is 90 we're getting a little
bit more lift not much
and we're making
equal errors false positive false
negatives
but we definitely have these questions
that are oriented around customer
service and
[Music]
that's essentially what these
uh what these four questions point to
and then segment three our small one and
this is why it's hard
you got
some of the questions that kick you out
of the segment and some of the questions
that kick you in the segment and there's
a little bit of both
um so you think about it this way in
segment one
these guys were high scorers
so now in segment one
in segment three you're getting low
scores on here
but now you're getting a different
scoring across here so these questions
are pushing you in middle of the segment
and
the nice thing is
we do okay at a small segment
no information no information rate is 52
almost almost purely random coin toss
um and we're able to beat that right
almost 30 points 78 so
again i i mentioned it's like
love it at 80 percent love to hit 85 but
at the same time given that it's a coin
toss
um and the data set then
at 80 we're doing okay and
obviously
if i use a far more sophisticated model
we could probably do a little bit better
but it goes back to the constraints the
customer wanted it in excel they wanted
to be able to batch load their own data
[Music]
and just kind of
see the levers and i think that's the
other part of the importance of logistic
regression and same thing with elastic
net it's just in a logistic progression
with a regularization function
is that
a business person can say yeah if i
score better with this question
i'm actually going to increase my my
loyalty scores or um
you know that that's partial uh
differential part where you say and this
is what i do when i do when i
analyze surveys i said look
if you increase your score for this
question by one point the probability
that they are one of your promoters or
you know frequent buyers and everything
goes up by five percent and if you
increase by two it goes up so it's a
very
uh
quantitative approach to being able to
say
how much do i need to move the lever
and i'll say in the
nps world and i was doing this in my
last company in healthcare
it was
it's a lot easier
to make a person go from a detractor to
a neutral
than it is to take a neutral person to
make them a promoter
um
and so as you think about ranking your
your actions that you're going to take
um
and and so you're in in this case your
dependent variable is their promoter or
they're not
and you rank the questions of importance
it'll tell you what's driving their
answers
um you should focus on ones that are the
low-hanging fruit but they're also easy
to get them out of the detractor hole
um and that's why actually we did that
in a couple places and it worked the
rate like our executives actually had
in their bonus plan that they had their
nps had to go up by four or five points
um and this actually created a bit of a
an action plan for them
so what do we do here so
we started out with our elastic net
we got the question we got the survey
down from 17 to nine questions that's
good
um
obviously the elastic unit is very good
we i looked at and i didn't show these
here but we looked at cv
rc curves confusion matrix i showed you
conversion matrices just so we could get
the few extra stats out of there
um
we have a model for each segment we use
our voting approach
overall the overall accuracy was it was
over 85
um and they said that was the client
said it was acceptable and um they
didn't have any we didn't have to come
up with penalties for misclassification
making a
uh false positive or false negative on a
segment is from a marker standpoint it's
not the end of the world maybe if you're
spending lots and lots of money
um
on something it may become more
important
but in this case it was really looking
to understand what's going on
within their customer segments
and that's it
um
so this so if we look at it
you can take a survey
make a binary question out of it apply
clustering maybe you like k n better
than hierarchical or something like that
um
get your segment labels and then apply
some machine learning against it and if
you get about a thousand respondents
as you've seen here even with 900
it'd be reasonably accurate and you can
do this to all any survey and and this
is just i do this on a regular basis
over and over with different surveys try
to
tease out some really good um
quantitative aspects of it
awesome thank you so much brian i i see
there's a few questions that are
starting to come in right now on slido
um but just want to let people know if
you want to unmute yourself or
raise your hand on on zoom you could ask
questions live too
lee i i see you had asked the question
earlier in the zoom chat
to brian i believe it said do you
reverse code
or any other item types would you want
to add any other context to that
question
can you hear me okay
yep i can
so earlier when you were talking about
item types you talked about liquor
scales and ten point scales and all that
i'm wondering if you use any
reverse coding or thurstone type items
to make sure people just start
repeatedly filling out the same value
over and over when you do your
assessments
i don't like to do that
we used to have a large um
i just have large conversations with
people not so much reverse coding but it
comes straight liners which i think is
what you're getting i know so
um
they give everything a five or
everything you know or whatever it is um
i look at it
i don't want to throw it out because
especially with the lycric scale
um
it's uh
you don't know that could be that could
be a very valid data point um
ten point scale you send you tend to see
a lot less straight what they would call
straight line
but it's in the it's always part of the
eda
and just because we used to have that
conversation all the time
thanks brian
i can read some of the anonymous
questions but again if you want to use
slido 2 you can put your name in there
and you can ask it live as well
but the first one was how are the
surveys conducted and collected
i've noticed youtube does surveys in
between videos
how did you do these
this survey was done
um through a marketing research platform
um
our
same actually most of them weren't done
that way so when i um so i said this one
is through a marketing research platform
i don't know who you are
um
and you just
plug it away and then we get it out on
the back end i think it's like
surveymonkey and something like that
i've done this exact same analysis with
data from survey monkey also
that was on
insurtech
industry we did
about 000 respondents from all from
different groups
um
and some of them are just
a lot of them are generally web based
where
um
if you've had a transaction just like
you say on youtube you know hey how did
you find this video you know give us a
rating one to ten or
um
uh sometimes you know you'll get a note
at the end of this
call you'll be asked to take a survey
and my healthcare company that worked
for had it that way too so
um
which was interesting because now you're
punching in numbers on a phone
um
you can still do one to ten it's just
it's a little different than
clicking a box
and you don't get comments as much so
then you
you have to ask
good questions detailed questions
i was curious if if you don't know who
is answering the survey and then you're
going and making changes
through the business how do you measure
like what actually
made that change in the survey or if it
was like those actual
customers or
uh
most of them most of these types are
directed at
you're at your customers so you so you
know your customers
and in fact
i did one recently at our bank
it was a survey and
so we had all their information
and
it was actually a rerun of a service so
they ran a couple pre-pandemic post
pandemic want to see what was going on
um
but it was highly skewed by the age
of the respondent and and
you know you just have to point that out
like you know you just i i'd actually
show a slide to our president to say
look
this is our real customer base this is
what they look like
this is what our respondent
group looks like by age and demographics
they are different they're not really
speaking for our 100 base but we will
like one of them was to pull the pull
the older segment out and then compare
the different segments
um
but yeah so you generally try well you
want to know if they're customers or not
so that's that's always an intro
question
um
or you know obviously if it's coming
through your own platform
um
then you know whether they're a customer
or not
um
but you if you can get demographic data
on people
highly recommended to do it if they're
if they're willing to you know ask just
a couple questions
um at the end
because it can be important just like i
said with our
ours was a kind of a technology-based
survey so
age matters
thank you
um a few other
anonymous questions in slido and one is
what distance metric are using are you
using for the hierarchical clustering
i use good old euclidean distance
um
so
think about a matrix where
we have 10 10 columns and we're just
gonna
you know
calculate square the distance between
um
along all those questions so it's very
very standard very clean
um
and because everybody was a one to ten
so i didn't have to like scale something
scale them all down like for instance
if if you're looking at web web data
and you've got bounce rate and page
views
you can't do hierarchical clustering
with that because page use is going to
be in the thousands and bounce rates
going to be as a percentage so you'll
have to
convert those so that they're an apples
to apples type metric these are all zero
which is zero to ten you don't really
have to do too much for that
thank you
uh lucinda i see you asked a great
question on slido is it okay if i pass
the mic over to you to ask that
yeah sure that'll be good
um so i saw that you hi brian how you
doing first of all
um
i saw that you
were using a
logistical regression for these which i
think is a linear base type um model but
i was wondering
if you've ever tried and i know not for
this one because you can't do rare
forest in excel
um but can have you used uh random
forest or other ones that are that deal
with non-linear
relationships well and
if you have like what's have you found
that there's a
find other find out other things
i have not for this kind of stuff but i
have and what i
um
what i was doing a lot of work in the
insurance industry
uh if you talk to actuaries that's all
they want to do is use
glm models of some form linear
um and so i showed them a standard data
set of
if you think about
age and income right is the older yet
you were supposed to have more income
but you often see it
as like a a you or a non-linear almost
like a bathtub where you've got people
that are very young that have a high
income then it goes down and then it
goes back up
and
there's so many
we see that a lot of times in the
insurance industry age of a house
you know
and those so the short of it is the
naive bayes actually does a nice job
at capturing the and that was the plot i
used to hold up to these people i said
here's a problem with your generalized
linear model all the time
and you're going to miss this every time
um
random force is a good one too it's a
little harder to explain and i think
that that's where it starts to get
challenging um in what sense is it
harder to explain
because you see you have you have the
the uh the future importance that's how
i use it i use future importance as my
list of things to pay attention to yeah
it is it is um so i i like it that way
but i also try to get into this
um because then they because they'll ask
me well
how much do i got to increase my score
by
um
and that was that's what that's when
the advantage of using a linear model if
you can you can't always but
and i was able to say look
you get the score by about five points
you'll be much better off or or you only
need to actually
with a lot of this stuff it's like
you'll see the difference between like a
six and a half and a seven it's like you
only need to get your average up a half
a point
to get more people over the line um and
that's where it becomes really useful is
that sort of marginal calculation
but
if it's just like what do i need to fix
then i think then i agree with you 100
like
especially in a more accurate like
you'll obviously probably be more
accurate with a random force model
and then you can then you can just say
hey this is my problem area it's pretty
clear
and that's what you focus on and then
that's what you have you know team
members and subject experts um there to
do
okay thank you very much huge fan of all
that you share with us
thanks brian thanks listen though
uh a few other anonymous ones one was
how big should the sample be to get good
results
my rule of thumb is a
thousand and the reason why is because
i've seen some
i remember calculating some stat for
logistic regression it's like you need a
minimum for one variable at 100
maybe 200 so you think about well
if i'm gonna have three variables i'm
going to be in the 5 600 range i'm going
to start splitting
but you know
you got to be in the thousand range
to to get uh
to get some decent results
and
it's
come through so many times like this
this survey had 900 i did nps with 1200
1400 and i've been lucky to do surveys
with 2000 and um
the nice thing is it doesn't take tens
of thousands i think is is a good answer
but
if you get a thousand sometimes it just
may take you more time though um and
that was a conversation i would have
with leadership is
you know
we're gonna have to run this several
months until you're gonna get an answer
that's usable and you just have to
understand this is the this is the rate
of answers we're getting
and we need x amount
and as long as you explain that up front
i think most people are very reasonable
to work with on it
[Music]
i wonder how that differs by
like industry or
i mean the types of surveys that people
are doing and
curious to like hear from everybody here
as well if you want to
chime in or
or share info in the chat too
i would say the more questions that you
have the more data you're going to need
um
someone had asked could you clarify the
survey design are we talking about three
binary main questions and several one to
ten scale supporting questions
no so the survey was just
seven i think it was 17 yes 17 1 to 10
questions
we didn't have we didn't have a binary
um
over time i actually got them to
introduce a binary into it
um
and so that was why we had to do the
unsupervised learning is to say
given these 17 questions
can i find
some groupings in which case we could
find three groupings
that are made up by how people respond
to different questions different
questions and you can see that one was
customer loyalty one was
customer service and i think the other
one was emotional validation so for
value sorry value
loyalty and service
and
um
that's
yeah like i always tell people
if you're doing a generic survey
you want to know something about them
please have a binary question
even if
um i had a good experience with this
company yes no like
um because then you can actually use
again those questions those supporting
questions are your variables to whether
or not they say yes or no
and that's why i i want you want to keep
it that way
that's really helpful um when making the
model is there a difference in setting
the response variable
as an ordered factor or a non-ordered
factor
uh in this case it doesn't matter
because it's just a binary um it's the
one or zero um
and
for
both the elastic net package and
i think i used carrot for this too back
then
um it just has to be a factor that's it
so your dependent has to be a factor and
that's it and it runs cleanly this is
all done in r so
um
i can't remember if python requires that
or not i think it can handle a one zero
as
a standard numeric
a few other
questions but i did all in case people
have to jump at the top of the hour i
did also want to let everyone know that
we've made a um
chat marketing channel on the r for data
science
slack community
and so i think it's a great place to go
to connect with each other too or if you
have follow-up questions as well
so i just want to point that out before
i forget to do so but
i'll put the link to join in the
chat
and then the channel is just chat
dash
marketing
but back to questions
one was for bank satisfaction scores
is there a trend by community between
historic issue issues such as predatory
lending practices
and current satisfaction rates
and if anyone has to add any other
context feel free to jump into
i
i'll say i don't underst no understand
fully that question but i will say
i read a jp morgan report out
uh
when did it come out
december of
2020 so at the end in december 2020
and it basically showed that
um
smaller regional
banks
had a way much higher satisfaction than
the national banks
and
part of it was due to the pandemic in
that
when they did the whole cares program
and the loans i don't know if anybody
remembers all that went up when the
the payment protection plan loans were
coming out so that you could keep your
employees
um
most of the big banks didn't you know
didn't really step up for their for
their customers whereas all the regional
players
um
really jumped in and did a lot of
loans i mean my bank is quite small and
we processed almost 10 000 loans between
the two programs and
i think it was a total of almost one and
a half billion dollars worth
for you know small local businesses to
keep their employees on the payrolls and
a lot of more like small restaurants and
small you know just really small
businesses getting
25 000 or 50 000 or whatever and and
then the sba once
um
would forgive it um in the whole program
but that was the whole cares program
that's the only thing i've seen
so satisfaction scores are generally
better for smaller banks
um
the uh i don't have any insight into the
predatory lending uh part of that
question
thanks brian
someone else would ask does your
experience with survey design come from
any specific text or purely from
implicit knowledge and career experience
mostly from career experience so i
started out
um
working in a marketing research firm
that i mean we would issue
thousands of surveys a year those that
was how they operated
um
and what i initially found out is that
um
they're just leaving so much on the
table because of that
you know you get a lot of in an old
school marketing was what was top box
you know percentage top box bottom box
but i was like that's not you can do
better we can do better uh
and so with this original original
data set that the cq stuff that
underlines underlined a lot of this that
created the survey and everything i was
lucky man we had a hundred thousand
responses to work from
um this specific data set alone after we
developed the cq
was 900 but
um
and then they kept re-running it so it
was growing
um
but
it's just
i think it's part of it i i've been in
this marketing type role so i had a
marketing research role did the quant
shop for them created one from scratch
and then i found that this approach i've
taken out of three other places and then
done the same thing mostly around nps
modeling
and it worked like we did the logistic
regressions for an insurance company
and it said you know his problem abc and
that's what they did they worked on
problem a and then we took the survey a
quarter later and problem a was now no
longer a problem a it was it had been
cured and actually the the mps score
went up three and a half points and of
course everybody's quite happy because
you know you meet a major kpi for your
uh
unit performance everybody everybody's
happy then
so it's
part of it is it just works um
i know we just said the top of the hour
but we have two more questions if that's
okay or do you have to run okay
um someone asked do you have any go-to
resource recommendations
on what
i'm assuming for survey design
but i'd also be curious to ask the
audience here as well if
if you have really helpful resources or
also maybe specific packages that have
are helpful in the marketing space
so
i have not found a good
uh survey design text
in fact we even had a class i had a
class on it marketing research and i
disagreed with the instructor so that
didn't really go so well
but uh
for packages the
clinic package out there there is a
great paper
um
by rob tipterradian and trevor hasty on
it and explains
um how it's different from original so
and i think for me i think i've read
that paper five times
just because i want to know it inside
and out
um
this was all standard like this is
simple code really that's why i didn't
want to get into
a lot of coding i mean carrot glimnic if
you and
understanding um
uh the den extend
package is extremely helpful i'm i've
sort of mastered that now
as far as being able to do it for
anything like i said i do it i use that
denogram
for text analytics all the time
um
and it's been a lot of fun actually so
the den expansion package shows you how
to
color any which way you want size it all
up flip it horizontal left right
and uh
i find it extremely useful in text
analytics visualizations when you're
comparing groups
those are the probably the three best
ones there i wish i wish i had better
marketing survey information and i think
part of it is there's just not that much
out there um
which is why i've sort of created my
own uh
page on what i think makes a good survey
and and i still clash with
with people in cx all the time and they
they disagree with me and i and
you know that's fine that's that's what
we're professionals about but
um
if i if i'm going to analyze the survey
and i get my say that's what i ask for
i ask for one to tens and i ask for
binaries
thank you one last question was
so i guess as you're designing this
survey then
how are do surveys designed to ensure
they are actually completed for example
how many questions are too much before
someone just gives up
we found between five and ten
um
and
closer to five is better
so in this case
we got from 17 to nine so we got a 50
reduction
[Music]
in longer surveys you're gonna have to
pay people like that's just the way it
is
um
the insurance industry one we had to and
i can't remember how much
they paid for it but
um
yeah
after five people will get especially
for a simple like
how did we do kind of thing
you've only got maybe three questions
before they're going to disappear on you
um so make that's why i said make them
count don't
don't um
make them overlap at all
you're not trying to spot the person
that's trying to game the system you
really want to get
in a short period of time how much
information can you get from people
awesome
thank you so much brian for sharing this
presentation with us and just answering
all these questions as well i
don't see any other that have gone
unanswered
but i also just want to open it up to
anybody that unmute themselves or raise
your hand
if there's anything we've missed
[Music]